So, it goes back, according to Islamic
teaching, remember the caliphs
Christians, [music] but it was not
sanctioned. So, this if you look at,
let's say the 1800s, to really
underscore the
the non-Islamic world they're at war.
Now,
even though it's perpetual and it's not
about whatever the topic may be, this is
not some operation because if it's been
around 10 years
and they can't I get that part. Um but
even
it was founded right around Uh obviously
there's a lot of overlap between what we
do and being that you're a Brit, is it
as bad as all that what we hear? Uh so,
I'm from America and what we hear about
America, I mean we have our own problems
with
Islam and Islamism and other issues and
we see what's happening in Europe in
general, but it seems like the United
Kingdom or Britain and is kind of like
the creme de la creme of absolute
madness. So, is that true and can you
speak to it?
>> Yeah, I mean you've you've you've been
there, but you haven't seen the worst
parts of worst parts of
>> out real quick. It's it is bad. It's as
as bad as people think it is. It might
even be worse than people think it is in
the United States. And we're here in
Hungary, which is obviously, you know,
very very different society. It feels
very Christian here.
What we're seeing in the UK, aside from
the fact that we obviously have this
growing Muslim population, it's growing
cuz the birth rates are higher, but it's
also growing cuz it's constantly being
topped up by immigration, especially
illegal immigration that's coming across
the channel, but the Muslim population
is projected to grow and actually to be
the dominant religion by the end of the
century.
Um [snorts]
and that inevitably transforms politics.
And the Muslim population are already,
you know, large, but still relatively
speaking to the rest of the population
quite small. But even with such small
numbers are already determining what
non-Muslims can do and say. So, we still
have a teacher from a school in Batley
that um
showed a picture of the prophet
the Islamic prophet Muhammad. I I have
to get out of the habit of saying that.
The prophet Muhammad to his class.
That was around four five years ago and
he's still in hiding with his young
family,
um, chased from his home.
Uh, we've seen the case of a guy who
burned a Quran as an act of protest
outside of the Turkish Embassy.
The Crown Prosecution Service tried to
get him done for having offended the
institution of Islam, which is not a
crime. This is the part of the state
that is responsible for, you know,
deciding what gets prosecuted and what
doesn't. They obviously couldn't charge
him with it because it wasn't a crime.
So, they got him on something else. He
appealed that, it was quashed, and then
the Crown Prosecution Service refused to
accept the fact that he'd won his appeal
and went after him again, effectively
trying to get him for blasphemy or
breaking a blasphemy law.
>> quick cuz I always hear this. So, when
we hear, for example, that the the UK
government is doing this sort of thing,
is it fair to say that that's because
there's a lot of Muslims in the UK
government and they're they're possibly
the ones who are really spearheading
this kind of thing? I mean, it could be
that, but I also think that this is
something that has
affected non-Muslim psychology more
broadly. So, there's a lot of
self-censorship. I mean, one of the
things that I like to use as a as an
example is that all non-Muslims do not
believe that Muhammad was telling the
truth. They effectively believe that
Muhammad was lying or he was crazy.
Yeah, it's like the it's like the Jesus
thing, you know, either either he's
Lord, liar, or lunatic. The same thing
applies to Muhammad.
>> And any anyone who is not a Muslim
believes that. But if you say that,
people stiffen in their chairs and
clutch their pearls because they feel
they feel instinctively that they're
saying something that is verboten that
they're not supposed to say.
And that's because the the Muslim
community is very politically active.
It's increasingly politically active.
We've just seen how important Muslim
sectarian politics is becoming. We've
got independent MPs. We've got a lot of
councils that have councilors that
represent sectarian issues representing
a particular sort of ethnic religious
demographic. We've seen this in the
recent by-election in Gorton and Denton
where there was sectarian campaigning in
Bengali and in Urdu.
They're increasingly influential in our
politics.
And the British police have this
approach and and not just the police,
but also the justice system, the
authorities have this sort of two-tiered
approach where anybody who kicks off,
anybody who is
the most aggressive, the most offended
is the one who gets pandered to and the
victims are the ones who are actually
targeted. So we had this case of a guy
who he works for the campaign against
anti-Semitism, guy called Gideon Falter.
Many people will have seen the video, it
went viral. I think it will go down as a
historic video where a police officer
tells him that because he's visibly
Jewish he has to leave the area because
you know, this this crowd might kick
off. So I'm I'm curious to know how you
see this in the context of Islamic
history more generally. How do you
understand what you're seeing? Because I
know you've said before that if if
Western countries
behave in a way that is kind of weak and
servile, that actually that just
encourages more dominance from from, you
know, the Muslim community rather than
you know, if we were strong like
Budapest is and and
and Hungary is, then actually we would
have less of a problem. Well, yeah, I
mean
this is why actually what we're talking
about England for example, um
it it it it even impacts me more in the
sense that it just seems more insane
than to the average person because I'm
so in tune with the history that
preceded all that sort of thing. And so
it's like the you know, it's complete
topsy-turvy of what was the established
norm which was yeah, we have a
civilization and a religion and a
culture and a heritage that we're going
to die for and those people have for a
millennium or over been attacking us for
it and have conquered and subjugated and
swallowed up the the majority of what
was once Christian land. Okay, so that's
how they saw it. Then they fought
constantly crusades and even
non-crusades. Sometimes they won,
sometimes they lost. So, that's why when
I we fast forward to today and I see
Muslims are now actually at their
weakest point compared to historically
when they were actually they were the
the more dominant force. But here
they're weak and you know, the West is
so powerful in all by every metric, you
know, financially, technologically,
militarily and all of a sudden these
Muslims are taking over. And so, what is
that? You know, how does one understand
that? And it's obviously because of a
complete It's not just forgetting
history and we know the adage of course,
those who forget history are doomed to
repeat it. It's not I mean, that's one
little element of it, but it's also I
think the rise of all these other sorts
of
philosophical dementia that's impacting
Western people, right?
>> Return. Yeah, these kind of like views
that have now
and they go underneath these euphemistic
kind of feel-good terms like humanism
and tolerance and multiculturalism and
these have become like mantras and
everyone has to
you know, kids in Europe or in America
are born and bred. That's who you are.
This is our strength, right? Diversity
is our strength. And um
all of that I I think when you put it
against the test, it all fails and it
leads to exactly where we're going right
now, which is why it's just suicide,
right?
>> You facilitated this kind of
philosophical awakening that the
antidote to that historical dementia
um by informing people actually of the
of the real history of Christendom and
how you know, so much more of the of the
world, the Middle East, Africa was
Christian and that the Christian lands
were shrunk to this tiny little oasis in
Europe and that creates a very different
philosophical perspective in terms of
how people think of you know,
what what they're defending, what Europe
actually is, the fact that you know, we
still have persecution in in the Middle
East today and the numbers of Christians
continue to dwindle. Why do you think it
is that Western countries and
particularly Western leaders
have have forgotten that history? I
mean, it seems like it's a conscious act
of forgetting that we've we've lost a
sort of um
a broader understanding of who we are
and where we're situated in history and
what's at stake here and how the West
actually historically relates to Islam.
>> Yeah. I mean, we're sitting right now in
a building that is on top of an Ottoman
wall in Europe.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah.
I think I mean, there's various answers
and throughout the years my views have
changed and I've now reached the point
basically that what has happened, this
thing that we're describing is by
design. It's just too It's just too um
organized for it to just be some natural
organic development. Which And by this
thing, I mean, of course, what we're
referring to, this sort of conscious
Western um abnegation of its own history
and heritage. Um [music]
I don't
You know, you could depending on where
you want to trace it, but it all seems
to start, of course, as all things do,
all bad things, in the 1960s.
Okay, and and I see this from an
academic point of view.
>> [laughter]
>> I see this especially in an academic
context. It was at that point where
Okay, so up until the 1960s, if you read
a a scholarly book written by a scholar,
an Orientalist as they were known,
talking about the Islamic world,
it would they would have been objective
and fair, but they would have at least
they would get what we're talking about.
Of course, there was Muslims and this
and that this and that and the other
thing.
After the '60s and the the one of the
most pivotal works is by Edward Said.
He's a Columbia professor, deceased now,
and I think his book was called
Orientalism. And the And the gist of it
was basically that everything that the
West says about the Islamic world is
made up and it's just they made it up to
demonize them so they can control and uh
justify by them. Okay, and that's that
so that just took over for that
particular field of studies, the East
and Islam in general. But it's gone now
to the point where, you know, it's we
can say that's some sort of problem from
an intellectual academic pursuit. But
it's everywhere you look around, it's
manifested itself this
this phenomenon manifests itself in all
sorts of different ways.
And in short, what is it? It's just a
hatred of the West.
By Westerners, [music]
okay? To just hate their history, hate
their heritage, hate their culture, hate
their religion, and then
and are forced to see everyone else as a
victim. So what I was telling you,
that's actually that's the beginning,
which is actually innocuous compared to
where it went. Where it went is now when
they do talk about history, they
actually give you the exact opposite. So
you you might have heard a quote I often
use from John Esposito,
professor from Georgetown University,
who was the editor of the Oxford
Encyclopedia of Islam. All right, so
he's definitely a uh a force to be
reckoned with, supposedly. And he has
this sentence where he says, "Five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed between Muslims and Christians
before the first Crusade came and ruined
all all of it and made Muslims, you
know, hate Christians." Of course, those
five centuries is when Muslims conquered
three quarters of the Christian world,
burned churches, enslaved thousands of
Christians, slaughtered thousands, okay?
So this is what I mean, that the history
has not just been ignored, it's been
rewritten to make the victims, this case
Christians, look like the aggressors and
the actual aggressors as victims. What
do you think of the way that this is all
being sort of reframed? Because in the
UK particularly, there's a lot more talk
now of, you know, understanding what's
going on as colonialism,
as settler colonialism,
lots of language of invasion. I know
you've said it's not really an invasion
because we're welcoming these people in.
It's an invitation.
>> How do you How do you think it should
actually be conceptualized?
Um what's happening like to In in the
UK. But I mean, of course Europe as
well. It's not just the UK.
Um, well, the the colonial thing again,
that's out of context. Again, most
people think when they talk about
history and Islam in Europe, they it
starts with the colonial era. As if
right before that, Muslims were living
peacefully there. Actually, at the time
of the in the colonial era to those
European powers, many of of whom were
secular like Napoleon, but others
actually saw it as the continuation of
the Crusades when they were going into
these Muslim nations.
Um, one of them, I forget his name, but
he went up to Saladin's tomb and
supposedly kicked it and said, "We're
back." And then yeah, he was a Frenchman
cuz the Franks were kicked out
eventually. Um, so obviously
>> Chad Chad move.
>> Yeah, very [laughter] Chad. So, he
obviously So, there was that living
memory going on for a long time. But
now, colonialism is, "Oh well, you did
this to us, so now you owe us." And um,
I guess that's why England is full of
Pakistanis and
>> Do Do Muslims see it differently? Um,
>> So, how do they see what's going on
here? Oh, well, so Muslims will play
that card, which is, "Oh, you're you're
a stupid European and you think you owe
me because of your crimes." Yes, I
agree.
>> made this point about Al-Qaeda that when
you look at the the sources, you know,
they were saying one thing to to
Muslims.
>> on the one hand, they will of course
say, "You're right." because it's good
for them. On the other hand, well, they
think you're a complete insane, okay?
But they also dislike you, not you per
se, but I'm just saying not Europeans or
infidels. Yeah.
Actually, yeah, [laughter] you
especially.
But um,
So, the Muslims, uh, if you look at
Al-Qaeda for example, but okay, so after
Al-Qaeda, we had ISIS. They were very I
like them because they were very frank
and refreshing. They just didn't lie and
they said, "Hey, we're fighting you not
because of what you did, but because
you're an infidel and we have to kill
you." Okay? Al-Qaeda before then and
most Islamic groups before and even
after ISIS, they played the game, which
is, "Yeah, we'll we'll we'll blame you
for colonialism, etc." But then amongst
each other we'll talk about how you're a
dirty infidel and we got to kill you,
okay? So that's definitely still the
case going on now, that phenomena, but
it's just human nature. This isn't like
some grand scheme that Islamic
organizations come up. It's just they go
in there and they realize, "Oh, these
people think they owe me something.
Okay, I'll go with it." Well, let let me
let me ask you about this
uh Ahmed al-Shara, the guy from Syria,
now the leader of Syria. He's just come
and and met with our Prime Minister and
there's this, you know, footage of them
on the streets of Downing on the steps
of Downing Street and everything shaking
hands, whatever. How is that perceived
by the West enemies? That this guy is,
you know, he What was he? The founder of
al-Nusra in Syria and now he gets to put
on a suit and come to Downing Street
and, you know, you've talked about
[music] the, you know, the impact of,
you know, being weak in the presence of
a bully. Mhm. What What does What What
is that signaling to the Islamic world?
That we're We've got our Prime Minister
sort of getting cozy with this guy.
Well, I've I've have an old theory that,
you know, I call it the bully the the
ground, you know, the school yard bully
theory, which I believe really totally
applies to the Islamic mentality.
And it's the exact opposite of how
Westerners approach them. And And it's
basically what What's a bully? You're in
school, you're in you know, high school
or whatever elementary school. Bully
starts testing you out, right? First he
starts with a snide remark, you ignore
it, and then maybe a little shove comes,
maybe you ignore it. Then maybe a
a punch comes and then before long
you're basically his slave.
>> [laughter]
>> In an Islamic context, yeah. But if you
punch him in the nose, then all of a
sudden he becomes like your best friend
and he respects you. And I submit to you
that is the Islamic mentality,
completely. Okay, so and that's why when
you bring, you know, these polite,
diplomatic, you know,
multi-cultural open Westerners and you
put them with Muslims, that's a horrible
mixture because the the Muslims when
they see that, that's like, "Oh, you're
you're weak. Now I'm going to start
pushing you around and I'm going to
expect more." Which is what happened
when you were describing, uh, you know,
the Quran burning. Right? The same
thing. I was in Denmark, same story. One
guy burns a Quran, they flip out.
Therefore, the guilty guy is the guy
who's exercising his free speech rights
or freedom of expression rights, okay?
[music] So, when they do that and you
actually capitulate and appease, that is
just a signal that now we Hey, boys,
let's take it up another notch. Okay?
Absolutely.
>> see over time when it's like the Danish
cartoon affair, Charlie Hebdo, every
single time
>> [music]
>> that the West cowers to the demands of
either external, you know, Muslim
leaders cuz they kicked off all around
the world and, you know, protesting like
the Satanic Verses, for example. Or if
they're, you know, kicking off
domestically, the state will always bow
down, bow down, bow down until it gets
worse and worse and worse. Now in the
UK, we have,
>> [music]
>> you know, talk of introducing this
Islamophobia definition and now they're
trying to rebrand it as an anti-Muslim
hate definition.
>> [music]
>> Which, I mean, there's been this whole
debate about, you know, whether or not
you define,
uh, Islamophobia as a kind of racism.
So, if you were to One of the things in
the original Islamophobia report
in the UK, this, uh, all-party
parliamentary group put this this report
together. And the examples that they
used of Islamophobic speech, I mean, you
would be your whole career is
Islamophobic. Uh, saying that Islam was
spread by the sword. Um, saying that
Muhammad was a pedophile.
>> Speaking of
>> All of this All of this stuff. I mean,
you're You're
>> a pedophile. Your whole thing about, uh,
the Zoot.
>> [laughter]
>> Which you need to explain, but, uh, um,
I can very easily imagine a situation in
the UK where you would get arrested for
talking about that, even though you're I
mean, you can explain it, but even
though it comes from Muslim texts. So,
how do How do people in the UK feel
about this? I mean, what you're
describing to me is essentially Okay,
we're a people, we have our own laws and
customs and cultures and freedoms. And
all of a sudden, we brought in all these
other people who don't have this and now
they're dictating everything and if we
use our traditional historic freedoms,
we get in trouble by our government. I
mean, do is this the way people are
registering it in the UK and if so,
what's the solution?
Depends on where you are.
>> despair? So I there's a lot of despair.
There is definitely a lot of despair. I
think outside of the kind of urban
centers, there's a real sense of
dispossession more generally. I think we
Britain was a very high trust society
with a very sort of delicate ecosystem
that had emerged, you know, quite in we
were very stable country. It's not like
here in Budapest where you have these
sort of like waves of history that have
been washing over the land and the
people. In in Britain, it has been, you
know, stable as a as a nation for over a
thousand years. We have this delicate
ecosystem that has emerged out of our
institutions, our laws, our customs. A a
lot went unspoken, sort of like quite
gentle manners and high trust. And all
of that started to wane
>> Then you throw in the Muslim element.
And then the 1990s come and you have all
of this mass migration and it's taken us
a really long time to even be able to
find the language to articulate any way
of pushing back against this and we have
this whole sort of like crisis of of
authority and legitimacy around, you
know, the liberal state enforcing any
kind of any kind of culture whatsoever
on anyone who comes in. So we've had
this sort of like multiculturalism where
we've just withdrawn and said you don't
need to integrate and, you know, you can
continue basically doing whatever you
whatever you want. And this has has
been a constant back and forth where
the state has just not really been able
to get itself out of this position of
paralysis and in, you know, feeling that
it's intolerant to impose anything
culturally on anybody who comes to the
country to ask any any any any ask
>> What do you get out of it then? What
what what what you as a nation I'm
trying to figure out. I can see all the
problems that let's say Britain [music]
has to deal with. You were telling me
how relieved you are in Hungary because
you feel like you can take a breath of
fresh air. You don't you don't think
you're going to get robbed or worse,
okay? So, surely there's a
advantage. What are you getting? Some
people say, "Oh, we have so many
cuisines now."
>> [laughter]
>> You can have you can have anything.
>> you know? That's worth the sacrifice.
Yeah, I mean the joke is that we've got
the recipe, etc. etc. So, so we don't
need it, but
um what do we gain from it? I mean there
are some
>> Like all I see is barriers. I see
threats. I see people afraid to go and
walk at night. I see rapes and grooming
gangs. I see high crime. So, you know,
we've been told multiculturalism
diversity is our strength and it's such
a great thing.
>> a lie. Okay. So, there's nothing to be
gained.
Especially now that you have the recipe.
This is a problem of the of the of the
elite, of the political cultural and
intellectual elite. The people are not
happy about this. And actually, I think
people have been, you know, much further
ahead in being able to articulate their
feelings about this because they're not
caught up in all of this kind of fluffy
academic civil service jargon and the
all the various sensitivities. They're
normal. They have common sense. They see
what's going on. They don't like it. All
it's done is
fragment and break down our society and
now it's actually a threat to our
democracy, preventing people from being
able
to say what they think. And I I mean I
said this to you. I think this is the
great uh sort of uh sym- symbolic or
metaphor um is that outside of our
parliament, now we have a lot of these
sort of like anti-terrorism defensive
architecture barriers all over all over
the country, but you know, in
particularly around Westminster.
And they've put this new sort of
anti-terrorism giant ugly hideous
barrier up um outside of our parliament
building. Which is really striking cuz
when I walked down to see the Parliament
here in in Budapest, and you can just
walk right up to it. There's no
defensive architecture whatsoever cuz
it's not needed. But, we have this great
statue of Richard the Lionheart outside
of Parliament holding his sword aloft.
And now he's behind this enormous
anti-terrorism barrier. I just think
it's such a sort of symbolic,
metaphorical thing. But, I mean, we have
people whose lives have been ruined by
this. And there's a guy, um, who
recently went to the United States cuz
he was from a Muslim background,
converted to Christianity, got
kneecapped, hospitalized, had his life
ruined, eventually has has had to flee
to the United States cuz the British
state just simply couldn't keep him
safe.
I mean, how do you How do you see that
in the context of Islamic history? Like,
where is that Where is that headed?
>> This is just unprecedented. There is no,
um, there's no parallel to this. There's
just, you know, Europeans, Christians,
or even non-Muslims in general being
weaker than and therefore being
subjugated by Muslims or being as strong
or stronger and being able to defend
against and sometimes even go on the,
um, uh, um,
offensive. This, you know, is so just,
uh, insane to understand that, you know,
like I said, Muslims are so weak at this
moment. And And that's why you have to
understand what everything that's
happening. This is why sometimes when I
hear people, Europeans or Brits,
complaining about Muslims, I don't think
they're really directing their their
anger at the right source. Like, Muslims
are Muslims. They just do what they do.
>> So, how how how do you How do you
diagnose the problem? And what do you
think we should do about it? How do we
fix it? Well, okay. So, first and
foremost, you have policy makers. Okay?
These people are responsible for making
policies. You wouldn't think it.
>> Yeah, I know. So, obviously, uh, they
should be doing their job in accordance
with the people's will, right? Which
means eliminating, um, of course, uh,
migration. And there's, as you know,
there's all this talk about remigration,
you know, as as suitable in whatever way
this may be suitable. But I think the
problem that precedes all this is of
course intellectual and philosophical,
okay, and spiritual. This is why it this
is why they're paralyzed. They can't do
it because they've been um compromised,
okay? Castrated. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
castrated. That's a good way to put it.
So, they can't think these ways. They're
just again, they're caught up and this
is the power of indoctrination when
you're a youth. They're caught up in
these terms, diversity and
multiculturalism.
And you know, they've been beat on the
head to be taught that oh yeah, your
ancestors are the worst people. Now, you
owe it to the Muslims. But given the
increasing limits on free speech, it's
like the sort of python starting to
close around us. Is it now or never?
Because like That's for you to tell me
you're the brick.
>> You tell me. You you know the history. I
know the history, but um yeah, it's
well, let's put it this way. It's it's
not that it's now or never. It's just
that every day that goes by it's going
to get harder. Okay, so it's going to be
hard. It's going to be pulling teeth
doing this, okay? One way or the other,
but it's not the kind of this isn't the
thing where if I just look away it'll
get better. It's just going to
progressively get worse. You know,
Victor Orban made an interesting
[clears throat] observation um because
he was talking again about migration and
how as you know, Hungary doesn't do that
whereas Western Europe. But here's the
point. Even if you do now, Western
Europe stop all migration, you they're
in there. That's it. You have a
homegrown population. What do you do
with that? And so that's again a
reminder of why it's a lot better to
deal with a problem in the from the
start when it's small and simple. All
Hungary had to do is put up a fence.
Problem over. But you guys uh even if
you if you were to say no more migration
starting tomorrow or today, um you have
the millions of Muslims and they're
procreating at higher birth rates and
they're aggressive and your politicians
and people are, you know, just weak to
put it simply. And no matter what, it's
going to get bad before it can get
better. But it's but the but I guess my
point is
>> [music]
>> the longer you wait the worse it's going
to get. So, I hear people like Rupert
Lowe
I don't know much about uh UK politics,
you can tell me, but he says the sorts
of things that I I imagine a lot of
Brits want to hear. He talks about
re-migration and so forth. Do you think
that's even a possibility? I personally
don't think that's that's possible. I
think this is uh and I I draw parallels
with Trump talking about, you know,
getting rid of all the millions of
migrate migrants and it can't be done.
And and Americans are upset and fighting
back and America's more of a
conservative nation than Britain, which
is already liberal and kind of Yeah.
milquetoast uh so
>> mean we saw we saw this in the UK
I think it was not last summer but the
summer before um where I think it was
social services tried to remove a child
from
their parents or something like that.
And I mean it kicked off. It really
kicked off. I think they were like
burning buses and stuff. And there was
just a riot. And and that was just over
this one small issue. If you went into I
mean, sure, we could try and deport all
illegal migrants and I absolutely think
we should and we shouldn't be giving
citizenship to anyone who comes into the
country illegally. Anyone who comes over
on a small boat from France should never
be allowed to stay in the country. They
should be instantly deported.
>> Right. We should be, you know, finding
all of the people who have come here
illegally, you know, even if they're
trying to claim asylum and they've come
across the channel,
just deport.
Um but to go in and [music] like
actively try to take people from within
some cuz we already have negotiated
policing, right? This [music] is a point
that David Betz has made, the academic
who is an expert in civil war. He's
already saying, you know, we are like
we've gone past the tipping point. The
fragmentation of our society, the sort
of burgeoning sectarianism is already so
bad. We're heading down this route. You
see certain communities where the police
have the they don't have to, but they do
go in and sort of gently gently, you
know, you know, how would you like us to
police you? There was some footage that
was released um during some of these big
protests where a police officer was
recorded saying to um a community to
could they just please go and deposit
their weapons at the mosque?
>> [laughter]
>> So, this is the this is the kind of
policing situation that we're dealing
with and it's not getting better over
time because the police are actually
aggravating the situation. And if
anything, they're kind of aiding and
abetting the Islamists, [music]
you know, anyone in the Muslim community
who wants to, you know, murder someone
for burning a Quran. There was a guy who
burned a Quran and then the police
released released his name and address
and effectively docked the guy.
So, the the the police and the justice
system are not on the side of the
British public. Everything's and I don't
know how we've gotten ourselves into
this situation. I know, you know, the
English have a reputation of being very
polite.
But we just like continuously back off
and and and and seed territory, seed
ground
for for for no good reason and it's
constantly to our detriment. So, the
message that we've actually started
sending not just to Muslims but actually
to the majority population is that if
you want to get your way, the solution
is violence. It goes back to your point
about the the bullying. You're say
you're you're sending the message to
people that they can do whatever they
like, they can walk all over you and
you'll just give them whatever they
want. And actually in the broader
context, I think you see that with Keir
Starmer's approach even to what's been
going on with Trump and Iran [music]
that he sends this message to the rest
of the world that Britain is just a
sitting duck. We couldn't even deploy
our military. We we didn't even deploy
our own ship to go and protect our RAF
base in Cyprus. The French sent a ship
which is a historical humiliation.
Um you know, it it just sends this
message to the rest of the world that
[music] Britain is a is one giant
doormat. And now people are saying, you
know, like with remittances or whatever
it's called, that people are coming and
are kind of looting us. Like we're
we're just here to be taken advantage
of. The British people are sick of it.
But the state's not on their side, so
they it's becoming increasingly risky to
actually air your opinion. It's risky
because
the state won't protect you from the
people who might try to chop your head
off. But it's also risky because the
state might arrest you.
>> Exactly. And this is what I mean when
when I first started hearing about these
stories, I thought they were it was like
not real. It was a it was a joke that
the European authorities are essentially
clamping down on people who are just
expressing free speech, which is true,
too, by the way. Um okay, so last
question. What Where do you see England
um realistically, not where do you want
it to be? I know where you want it to
be, but where do you see it in, let's
say, 30 years?
>> Oh god. I mean, I don't like to think
about it because it's too upsetting.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm naturally quite pessimistic. Um
I
I get quite upset thinking about it
because I think about, you know, the
England of my childhood, the England of
my
my dad's, you know, childhood, my
grandparents, and
you know, my grandparents fought to
defend our country and to keep it free.
>> [snorts]
>> Um
and
we had a we had a a case recently on um
the television show where a veteran said
in an interview on
main mainstream national television
that
and he'd fought in World War II, one of
the last remaining living veterans, and
he said it wasn't worth it.
And the
the the host said, "I'm sorry you feel
that way."
Uh
but
>> Racist.
It I mean, you could see how
uncomfortable they were that this guy
had said what everybody else is
thinking.
>> [music]
>> Um
the demographic projections are bad,
right? So, I mean bad [music] bad for
the native British community. Um, we're
set to be a minority by 2060.
So, that's within my lifetime. And I
think a child born today
um, by the time they're my age will be
living in a country that has been
completely transformed. And the thing
that I'm concerned about
is that people don't realize
that our liberal so-called secular I
mean Britain isn't really totally
secular cuz we have an established
church. We're not secular in the way
that the United States is.
That
that culture that has allowed us to have
the freedoms that we have, that has
allowed our liberties to flourish is
distinctively Christian. It doesn't
exist anywhere else in the world because
it doesn't exist outside of a Christian
context. It requires those Christian
foundations for all sorts of theological
reasons that are too much to go into
now. And if you see, as we are seeing,
Islam projected to become the dominant
religion, Islam has a very different
view of the relationship between
religion and politics. We're not talking
about Islamism here. Like even Islam
itself is a totalizing religion. It does
believe in in in religious law, in using
public authority to save men's souls.
>> Mhm. And that is very un-English. It's
very un-Christian. I mean there are
there are Christians of course
throughout history, even in the United
States, Puritans who thought otherwise,
but the English tradition is not like
that. And that's the reason why we had,
you know, these liberties
grew and flourished in the United
Kingdom.
And I think as you see an increasing
dominance of [music]
Islam within our liberal democratic
politics, that changes the character of
liberal democracy. I mean I'm not sure I
don't I'm not entirely sure that, you
know, it won't remain liberal democracy.
It will just become this kind of
sectarian voting where certain ethnic
communities have representatives. We're
already kind of starting to see the
beginning of that now. Exactly.
>> Then the whole system will change. So my
fear is that within my lifetime I I I'm
fairly sure that I am going to see my
country completely transformed. The
British people already feel bereft and
dispossessed of their inheritance.
Nobody wanted this. Nobody consented to
it. Everybody voted against it. The like
the the the majority of British people
continuously when polled don't want mass
migration. They get They're against it
at the ballot box. It continues to
happen against their will. It's being
imposed on the population. You know,
people want to live in a in a high-trust
society like the one that we're in, you
know, today in the in Budapest, which is
I have been so bowled over by how, you
know,
freeing it feels to not be worried about
getting robbed
>> [laughter]
>> every time you go out in the street. Um
so I I think that
and I I know this is something that
Americans care about, so if you have an
American audience, it's kind of a plea
to you guys. America is doing us a real
service by standing up for our freedom
of speech and making that into a
diplomatic issue and by making mass
migration into a diplomatic issue and by
emphasizing our shared civilization
because the British people need help in
standing up for protecting their
inheritance because the establishment is
really rigged against us.
>> [music]
>> Um so I I get upset when I think about
it. I'm worried about it. It is it's
worth fighting for because it's what we
have in the United [music] Kingdom is
such a treasure. It's such an aberration
in the history of mankind.
And
for us to
to throw that away,
I mean it is the greatest possible of
all historic betrayals. Mhm.
Absolutely. Downer.
>> [laughter]
>> Sorry we have we have to end it on such
a high note, but
well, well Emma, thanks for joining me
and your brutal honesty, which which I
think is actually very important. People
need to hear the truth. I think it's
part of the problem is people keep sugar
coating it, but the more they see the
reality of it, I think the better, you
know, the chances that that won't come
to pass. So
>> I hope so. Thank you for joining me
again. Keep your head attached to your
body and keep fighting the good fight. I
will. Thank you.
Bring back
the fire
and the righteous